we went through some twists and turns we
looked at this thing and we wanted to
reform it rephrase it as a quadratic so
that we could take advantage of the fact
that once it's in ax squared plus BX
plus C right we can look for the
discriminant less you and define it to
be greater than or equal to 0 once you
do that those are the conditions for X
to be real and it must be real so you go
through this it does take I took maybe
four or five lines just to make sure i
did this properly flip around the
inequality of the correct way once you
do that at pops this quadratic and this
is the solution so that quadratic
inequality okay you're between a third
and three okay now we are just shy of
actually finishing off like where would
I finish that one third is this value
down here a third okay and the three as
you can see my scale is not fantastic
because I drew this before I knew
actually I already knew but before you
knew that it was a third of three okay
so really this should go well if that's
one then that'd be too and that'll be
three so this actually goes
substantially higher okay but just for
now just cuz I left it there that should
be free so there's my range there's my
range this is a very hard question
really so you guys are doing well if
you're still grasping what's going on my
last little bit is I really want to know
where these are I want to know where
these are and it's within my reach to
find out their locations so for instance
i would say what happens when y is the
third what happens when why is it there
and I simply have to solve this
one-third equals minus the plus four on
x squared plus 2x plus 4 just like I did
in this line right I just want to get
this as a quadratic in X okay i guess i
would cross multiply I'd have x squared
plus 2x plus 4 over here I would have 3x
squared minus 6x plus 12 over there
let's tidy this up shall we if I bring
everything over to the right hand side
this is going to become 2x squared this
is going to become
minus 8x collection frightened to it and
i subtract four from both sides so this
is going to become plus eight everything
is even so i'll divide through which
gives me in this and this is not just
factor I zabal it's perfect it's a
perfect square right this is X minus 2
all squared so therefore I have one and
only one solution namely X is equal to
two right there okay so there's my point
ok i will rehearse that process to find
the other point the higher one by
putting in y equals 3 instead of y is a
third for y equals 3 it's probably less
old and then you put it into what you've
already found it I said I put it into I
put into a pot on where we have to put
it there ain't no one oh you mean this
one yeah yeah yeah you absolutely could
because in some ways like I've already
done that step um or alternatively like
you can actually see this is a bit
advanced but you can just machine it out
if you like because of how similar these
two are and the fact that I'm literally
taking the reciprocal right what you
will find is that you'll get when you
get to this step you'll be solving this
everything would be exactly flipped
around because this um this minus 8x
will be a plus 8x and say for it will
become a plus 4x and therefore when you
factorize it will become X plus 2 all
squared you can go through that it just
takes that many lines or if you go
straight in there you'll get that
solution out so x equals a negative 2
for that guy and so I've got that point
over there okay there is a there is some
symmetry to it and that's only to the
fact that that you rather than Omega us
were very close to each other okay but
as you can see is neither odd nor even
symmetry right because it's not
happening around the origin and it's not
happening about the y axis okay but it's
a beautiful graph the calculus involve
you just needed to know how quadratics
work and then we solve this question of
domain
and that's what I live for yep what does
expose disease that one from doing this
same process with three in stem occur I
just kind of shortcut it because the
process is the same leave for the
quadratic formula yes one of us almost y
equals zero about how you know so you
can use the you still care just okay I
mean we've already we kind of dealt with
this earlier when you weren't here
because we already established by
regions by regions why can never equal
zero because there are no intercepts and
so that's why we're always it's love
it's that's for me to be here and so in
some senses because I've kind of already
dealt with it that's why I don't even
mention it okay um that was just about
the fact that we'd already identified
that will never hit the access right so
y will never equals it yeah why can't
equal 0 and if you put in y equals 1
right um you get this solution that's
that's what just what happens if you
solve it instead of putting the third or
three you put in one now just one little
quick note right do you remember and
this we much faster that you already
have the pieces they're one of the grass
that I gave you was from memory I think
it was x squared plus 1x yep that's the
one okay and this was relatively simple
it was nice and symmetrical in look like
this ah yeah yeah you're happy with that
do you remember it vaguely ok now the
beautiful beautiful thing about this
process okay is it works exactly the
same can you see I can pull exactly the
same trick that I did before can you see
that okay watch what happens um I am I
remember we said we were we were just
content to say I don't know where those
are there somewhere they turn but who
knows where they are if I answer this
question of domain and range I will find
out where they stop okay because I'll be
above there and I'll be below there
right let's see if we can pull the
pieces together let's turn it into a
quadratic help me up x squared plus one
equals y X yep okay so let's just put
that guy in general form like so
okay from here that big leak was saying
the discriminant has to be greater than
or equal to 0 for a real domain for real
values in order for this thing to be
solvable okay so therefore I say what is
the discriminate in this case it's going
to be b b squared minus 4 a c you agree
with that b squared minus 4ac I want it
to be positive okay y squared minus 4
that is evidently easy to solve that's y
minus 2y plus 2 okay so I want this thur
to be positive right I've got a I've got
a quadratic you want the parts the plaza
there the outside part right so you're
going to get y is less than negative 2
or Y is greater than to bear right so do
you see how I went from here and said oh
look I've got way those why those there
I am that's where it exists that's where
I got real goes inside here I don't get
real values function does it isn't
define okay then of course all you need
to do is I'm supply that back into here
and just by because it's a beautiful
function okay you just get one and
negative one ok so we're calculus
involve just understanding the way
quadratics work pulling out this sky and
then seeing that's great isn't that
beautiful you can just find those points
with such elegance surgeon I don't know